je suis pas là s'il te plaît je suis pas
là
oublie je vouis juste faire la
surprise je suis plus à l'hôpital tu
rourner à l'hôpital c'est ça c'est
normal qu' quitté insupportable am
nerveux tu parles que de toi tu voulais
le feu à l'immeuble avec Spirit
pardon
pardon j'ai des cadeaux pour les enfants
je suis calend jeis en convalesence il
me faut du repos s pas
bien V sur un
pigon petit
momentffe je peux
rentrer pas pe que je vous pte la gueule
vent qu'est-ce que tu veux me
prouver faire ma vie avec un
tu crois et moi on a une
chance tuux pas qu'on regarde la
télé me débrouiller tout seul avec elle
frç avec elle
soyz pas s que tu viend pas jeend
plus moi je la lu
donne Déré comm
fille je suis bien bonne de te
suivre c'est là précisez-moi ici ici que
quoi là où tu veux
m'embrasser